citizens of reject Nation we are back
for more benign of the nine today we're
gonna do episodes five by 15 I believe
in 5 by 16 unless one of them is just so
good that we have to stop and discuss it
immediately Greg how are you feeling
don't talk to me don't talk to me either
just subscribe to the patreon.com the
real rejects you know what to do all
that good stuff let's just hop into it
everybody make room Amy needs adequate
space to do her signature dork dance I
don't know if there's gonna be a door
chance oh there will be a dork dance
it's a little bad news envelope no
that's nuts Sarge teller envelope size
doesn't matter if I'm being honest I got
a much bigger envelope oh god oh it's
very unhelpful mine was bigger too uh
the black people
I'll open it
do it harder I opened it
oh
what's happening wow
that's my future wife
so
a reception dance is gonna be a good one
this case will be the last one we ever
worked together as detective so it has
to be perfect I present to you A Serial
arson case and the fires seem harsh in
case status is about to be heka moist
don't call HR we are getting married
because Melvin Sterling is coming in to
help us with the case sure
hey I was going through your calendar
who's this guest star gonna be being
that I am your campaign manager Miss
sleuthing on your Rivals yeah I'm gonna
spill the beans why would you ever
intentionally spill beans they're one of
Nature's most densely packed protein
sources and they remain unsullied you
know what she meant and John Kelly yes
that's right there are two John Kelly's
how are these not the same man you
should see their wives or should I say
life but God it's the same picture
maintaining the chorus and blazing a
path to a new future I'm kidding it's
remaining on the course unbelievable
none of these men have any interest in
advancing the NYPD Advance the course
but do you know what kills dinosaurs
asteroids no use steroids who you are
going to kill these dinosaurs use
steroids to kill these dinosaurs come
meet Melvin oh you can call me vin
but where is nerd look in the mirror
Jake uh took the words right out of my
mouth say hello to the nine
not brand new
that's your own wheels yeah it's a
taxpayers money protect or stuck driving
their crappy old cars mine's the oldest
I've never felt so abandoned and I was
actually abandoned they found me in a
swap we'll do a drawing for it but until
then no one touches it oops too late I
left the ranch handprint on the
windshield
[Music]
let's do it I'll take even Clues you
take odds great and
I out of your coffee but I love a
kombucha great I walked to a kombucha
store everything okay you little
of course it's gonna be like Sky fire
he's the arsonist maybe we should switch
gears a bit and get back to some good
old-fashioned police whoever said in
these fires is clearly trying to
humiliate Finn you know make a puzzle
you can't solve so maybe we should focus
on people that don't like you maybe
another Puzzler wants to take you down
maybe Melvin's doing it himself Amy
likes my plan great so then why don't we
just get this coat back on you and I'll
help you get out of the door here and
we'll see you tonight okay
hi the best right oh yeah
so overcompensate I paused suggestively
before I said experience so he would
know it wasn't really a compliment oh he
felt it invented the pause Raymond Holt
and Olivia Crawford oh snap anyway I
just wanted to say what a privilege it
is to be up for the same job as a man
with your tenure oh damn she paused you
an error I am certain Olivia I made
I would add a social media officer to
every Precinct interesting I plan on
eliminating precincts altogether all
right no precincts that's not how we do
things that's exactly what both John
Kelly said Oh no you're nothing but a
Kelly and I don't want to say you're a
dinosaur but yeah dinosaur
wow a Hulk now Holt you got this kill
her and steal her strategy what do you
think of Melvin stermley you mean my
future husband oh so you like his
puzzles and his face body and brain and
body honestly even makes all other men
seem really stupid and ugly
we must solve one of Vin's puzzles to
enter rearrange the letters of this
phrase to reveal a place in the world
meet a brainier stud a oh come on
there's no place with that many letters
in it Paris Amsterdam a Bermuda Bermuda
Triangle sad anus loser I go in you know
I feel like these puzzles are actually
very pointed forget it I got this
Microsoft
I don't want to figure out that set anus
loser go in yeah
I'll get it by the end of the episode I
need this car too I'm sick of riding my
best bit of work every day well being on
the seat behind just no picnic either
all right here goes oh what oh my God it
says Dairy I want they all say Terry no
way he cheated what I didn't cheat I bet
every slip in there says Terry he filled
it full of fake people who the hell is
Norm scully's first name it is
you want unfair and unsquared I'm gonna
prove it and if we can't we'll plant it
no Charles I need your help Terry's the
one who placed the the order for the car
jealousy is an ugly emotion that I don't
feel besides Amy picked my plan to come
here why would I be jealous of Ben
because of his body and face and brain
and body have you seen his body no
wonder the Saturday crossword replace
Sam with him Sam must be pissed I heard
the only place that buys his puzzles now
is Parade Magazine a five-letter word
for a game popular nursing homes Bingo
you know what Amy it's your last case
you decide should we go with Vin's wacky
little plan or should we go with Sam
Jepsen my exceptionally solidly wacky
little plan fake but this is Vin's world
and I think we should go with his
strategy sound good yeah yeah sounds
great live life one stanza at a time
or his name is Sam and he's spelling it
backwards uh yeah in design today's
puzzle using only one of each of those
letters isn't that the craziest thing
you've ever seen remember that time we
investigated The Disappearance of Mrs
Jackson and it turned out her parrot ate
her bones and all that was pretty crazy
that was crazy for real I'll take the
mat corner you take the mar corner and
we'll have patrolman take the Max and
m-a-l cool yep very cool okay great I'll
get the surveillance equipment this is
kind of a fun plan you're going to stake
out Sam's apartment then when he sets a
fire bin it's gonna look like a dummy
that's right oh I'm a handcrafted no
it's not gonna claw
you're halfway to Palpatine there are
two friends jokes in this episode
already I'm a creature of the past I'm a
dinosaur no you are not you're the best
man for the job and I think you know
what you have to do to get it believe in
myself and give a great presentation not
even close that's the head of the
committee over there gorging on suck ass
the best commissioner the NYPD has ever
had if you're not the commissioner I
will do good things for the city now get
over there and crap all over Olivia's
ideas Patrick nice to see you hello
Raymond shall we small talk
huh I suppose you could call it that I
mean
right you don't need to worry about her
we had to nominate a girl for PR reasons
there's no way the NYPD is ready for a
female commissioner well we are ready
for a gay black man grab a crab cake
before we start real crap big chunks
remember where you came from Holt nope
nope you worked too hard gay black man
turn
woman later for yourself sister we found
a Smoking Gun play at his gun
what I don't see anything focus on the
butt he squeezed his cheeks before he
opened the slip he knew his name was on
it it was a preemptive celebration
clinch
I just kept hearing the blinker
here the keys take the damn car Terry
doesn't deserve it you do that is why I
became a cop
good man our first presentation tonight
will be from the 99th precincts Captain
Raymond Holt Raymond
rescind your consideration I was just
told by a member of the selection
committee that they have no intention of
ever choosing a woman to run the NYPD
someone who has been denied opportunity
because of who I am I cannot stand by
and watch it happen to someone else what
are you doing come on stick to the plan
election committee that will judge all
of the candidates fairly and let's be
honest crab cakes were only so-so thank
you
enemies well he just sat down on the
Plaza okay he's opening up his backpack
he's got a bomb let's wait for it to
explode he's eating with a spoon it's
soup he's eating soup definitely pull
that a lighter nope it's not a lighter
it's a bumblebee Pez dispenser he's
making a phone call Quick get the
Powerball need a Pez like that I did
something bad yeah you set some fires I
proposed to Gretchen and she said no so
you set some fires so I left Myrtle
Beach two weeks ago and then you set
some fires so I got back home today
yeah all my fish were dead Okay so Sam
wow probably get back to my corner just
because I was wrong about Sam does not
mean that VIN was right dude your core
is on fire oh I knew it you knew it
Finn is not a cop why do you keep siding
with him instead of me oh let me guess
because he was right and the building
was on fire and he's perfect are you
jealous of Vin because it's a gross
emotion but yes I am a little bit
jealous of the super smart supermodel
this was our last case together I'd
never experienced the feeling of
jealousy or sexy Bee muscle that I don't
understand how to tone he told me it's a
lot of bicycle crunches crunches on a
bicycle yes try it
reason to be jealous of him
I don't want you to wake up one day and
wish that you were with someone as smart
as you are
when as smart as I am you really he left
the arsonist m-a-r but they were going
to spell m-a-r-r-y conjugate means Mary
yes and who wants to marry Ben the lady
from the bar hey unscramble this you're
going to elge
excellent puzzle work you froze your
slip of paper so that when you pull the
name all you had to do was find the cold
one you got Gina cushion for her chair
you let Charles show you 130 pictures of
nikolaj brushing his teeth you heinlich
Scully twice on the same peanut I also
solved America
how did you get Hitchcock and Scully to
agree to this I washed their car and
told them it was a new one they're
napping in it right now
Captain Crawford is here to see you
thank you
Frenemies do you know what that means
are you trying to imply that I'm too old
to understand a portmanteau I am not
poor Quanto good word feel free to start
calling me commissioner now be your only
time I plan on calling you is to hear
you concede it's gonna be hard to hear
anything once I've crushed you into a
fine powder a fine powder that will
choke you until you die yes
uh thank you for catching her with a
brilliant puzzling mind like yours on
the case actually Jake solved it
couldn't have done it without your help
you're making a mold of me for the
upcoming Bodies exhibit as they should
your body is you should join me for a
puzzle night sometime
no Jake is taken he already has a friend
hangout offer now let's treat your
centerfold
good man Charles
ah we get it we get it all right Next
Episode here we go on my Mark I will
turn on this fan gently startling our
bird do East file box canyon where he
will encounter Charles holding two pots
and out of the ceiling there where he
will be greeted by scary Rosa holding a
scary picture of an owl this is not
gonna work you an upside down garbage
can propped up by a hockey stick and
connected to a string that Gina is
holding she pulls it he's trapped and
Terry releases him outside let's get you
home to Mama
oh yeah it flew right into
it
[Music]
oh animals always die for the sake of
Comedy that's funny
It's the funniest thing I can think of
[Music]
it's right he signed up for this signed
up as a one-time payment bribe I'm not
selling nutraboom it's clearly a pyramid
scheme first off it's not a pyramid
scheme it's a conical tiered multi-flow
through medical marketing entity yeah
canceling the contract canceling it was
that easy to get out would I be here of
scamming my closest friends we're your
closest friends whatever I'm not
accepting the worst you are let's go for
the honeymoon and no other reason all
right Sergeant Santiago commander of the
nine nines uniformed officers reporting
for Duty hey nice you look great you
won't be abusing your power like this
with the officers downstairs will you of
course not I'm just excited for my first
day yes I remember my first day as a
sergeant I bet my uncle Jeffrey was
struck by a Subway in Maine
the work aspect was quite exciting are
you ready for your
and still keep their attention my
recommendation would be you start with a
small attainable goal something you can
accomplish quickly perfectly and
publicly the best way to lead is to
always achieve all your goals yes it was
meant to be pressure is an important
part of success just remember it you
represent all Latina police women right
now hell yeah
just find the biggest Beat cop and beat
him down we need to cancel our neutral
contracts we need ten thousand dollars
what's that I'm sorry it's payment for
the last shipment plus the cancellation
fee plus the restocking fee plus
something we call a cowards charge
congratulations thank you I'll write you
a check is gratuity included Charles no
no
these days
for the no payment option you just need
to sign here enrollment in nutracore
it's our charity organization doctor is
spelled with an E it's the British
spelling that
and if you don't cooperate we'll have no
choice but to file a report against the
company you signed a contract and that
is binding no one gets special treatment
officer
oh yeah the guy from Super Troopers yep
yep and he's directed many episodes of
Psych specialist this L he 'd been
assigned to intimidate you
Charles
stanking her
so bad I know what we should start with
oh I'm sorry officer Jennings Gary
Jennings officer Jennings okay will you
just pause so I thought you were looking
for suggestions which I have a lot of
nope not why I paused anyway
yes I am because our first order of
business is cleaning this floor
Charleston Charles come here terrible
sir I mean no one's seen the CEO's wife
in years people think she's been
murdered that's just a rumor just on a
retreat how do we get in you ask by
attending today's meeting a president's
Club Admiral level nutrimasters at the
Nutra Tower life
you know someone who's a high level
nutriboom distributor who can and he
looks exactly like you yes you really
think it'll work Charles it has to it's
for our honeymoon
hour don't trust it okay we're meeting
at neutral boom HQ starts in two hours
Charles you're going as Bill and I'm
going as one of your new recruits Bill
why is it vibrating is your cell phone
in here no I'm sure it's not a sex type
all right these people really it's a
electric razor tell us all about
yourself let's start with my whole
family history I was abandoned in a
playground as an infant and here I am
oh here's a list of all the nicknames I
go by Big Bill big Eric big Drew Big
Dave super thick just write them all
down for us and that's why the number of
belly buttons I have is two one zero
Kyle XY
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello
that's it okay now let's work on your
wig only you and I know our naughty
little secret
okay I think boils
really wanna passes me you're going to
need to learn my patented neck massage
technique yeah I don't really see that
coming up thanks for your help bill it's
literally coming up all types of
successes rousing resounding
smashing
but you told Captain hold it went great
in such a normal way I'm a terrible
manager I've got this super eager
know-it-all in my squad who keeps
derailing me with all his ideas and I
can't get anything done oh reminds me of
someone
nine follow-up emails about the briefing
no 30. you gotta know me guys I think I
would know if my Gary wasn't Amy
the new issue of stationery monthly yeah
[Laughter]
recruit I signed up no new recruit boom
boom boom boom
boom and get inside and unlock my
neutral future I love your energy boom
boom I love you your energy boom boom
just the security guard yeah
have you seen all these posters of David
stolen's wife Debbie I'm happy healthy
and alive yes you are I'll be real dead
all right Bill said that the officers
investigate that hello Admirals please
turn your eyes to the monitors for a
special hello from neutral Elite Jay
Champa secar
and there's our destruction Dr David
stovelman I had no idea my amino acids
could be so high or so low
Harry how did you used to deal with
having a Navy I didn't have to do
anything you've always been great I'm
drowning fine when you got too difficult
to deal with I'd pull rank did that work
no oh my God I'm so sorry
Jake and then eventually over time
they'll each become 10 easier to deal
with Gary will never find love he is
unlovable
[Music]
oh cool well congrats your baby rolled
over early like who cares and that is
how you deal with an Amy you talk about
something she's not interested in tell
her she walks away
whoa Gina you genius genius Gina Gina
yes you don't know about this nobody
does Charles you clearly just read some
weird blog posts first of all bought
mango.com is that a weird blog it's
infotainment second
hello Bud boom boom boom boom Bill what
are you doing back here this floor is
closed on the weekend you're really sore
from Pilates but nutraboom doesn't allow
Pilates it's a pseudoscience oh no most
recent sexual partner boom boom boom
boom you see him off man your voice is
different you're not sucking on your
signature lollipop right give him a neck
massage what are you doing back here I
know what's going on you're fishing for
one of my patented neck massages aren't
you
there's the bill I know turn around and
give me that neck you're not gonna do it
from the front well of course I mean
that's how I do it oh that's the good
stuff boom boom boom boom
perfect diversion
[Music]
eye contact
wait what's her he formed a line Jake
you're going to line
excellent delivery they're terrible at
making shakes right the only listed
ingredient is foreign substance oh yeah
you really think that's what I thought
was interesting about it I don't know
it's a payment for 100 grand to scepter
core not one of those Black Ops security
firms that uh we don't have time to talk
about this your dad's birthday is the
same day that Debbie stovelman went
missing last year oh right but it is
enough to make stovelma nervous we just
have to get to him oh no I have to go
his bill again no don't worry he isn't
big enough to earn FaceTime with the
founder we have to take this to the
highest level Super Trooper guy Jay
Chandra say car yes hey Gina Chandra say
car I gotta commit that to memory so my
friend Wanda she just loves the ocean
the Pacific the Atlantic the Indian oh
what is her take on straights because I
love the bearing yes you should just do
what I used to do when I needed to
escape you literally Escape you always
be on the Move never be static like a
shark's right that is what we did but
you all did that but Rosa how did you
yeah
you guys are good
Gene is just under the desk we wanted to
talk to you about nutribune all right
boom boom guys boom boom we're with the
NYPD oh my god seriously you guys have
to save me can you get me out
you pretend to be happy too if you know
what they did to me testicular torture
yeah yeah oh they kidnapped my dog okay
well no need to compare steaks although
I doubt your dog cost ten thousand
dollars you can't put a price on life
you're absolutely right thank you so
much for your help sir
sergeant
Sergeant oh my
yes it's a full-time job avoiding this
guy
finally get these shelves out
[Music]
no I was trying to tell you not to use
that wall it has water damage noted
[Music]
can't believe we're working a sting
operation with a celebrity I know I feel
like we're in Ocean's 11. you're such a
Clooney oh and I'm Elliott Gould wow
yeah skip right over pit and Damon
no oh no neutral core guys they're
taking Jay it's not a pickup it's a
throw in taking him to the celebrity
center
you can see for yourself if you'd like
Bill I will say for myself but I am not
Bill good one bill yeah Jay oh my God
boom boom guys what oh no oh the van
thing yeah Jay the van thing those are
just my friends from nutraboom they were
worried about my amino acid levels so
they rushed me straight here to give me
more or less of them why are you talking
like that what did they do to give you
that tortured truth they found my
dog he was wandering around a park for a
year come on man pull it together these
people are evil remember David stollman
murdered his wife you mean me whoa
she is happy healthy and Alive it could
be an imposter hey Captain it's turning
into a sci-fi movie I couldn't deal with
this over eager officer who kept
pestering me oh you have an Amy yes
I know exactly what it's like to be you
he used to be an Amy no I never had your
level of insecurity I was referring to
oh yeah interrupting me with all his own
ideas were they good ideas I don't know
I didn't listen to them she just yes I
did you see managing Amy is not a chore
it's a pleasure and a tool yes you're a
massive tool
but you should always listen to an Amy
because they will only make you better
at least that's my experience thank you
sir
gay black man I thought you were
murdered I was never dead and what was
that 100K payment to scepter core for it
was to get you off the grid because the
feds were investigating you so you're
still working for nutribullom working
before I am nutribu I am the new trip I
haven't committed any crimes that anyone
can prove so you can try your luck with
the feds or you can get your money back
and go on that expensive honeymoon boom
boom I know everything oh really because
you don't know about my big ass moral
compass
boom boom also can you tell us how to
get out of here this place is a real
maze
we're never seen again I want to
apologize I ignored your ideas and that
was the mistake tell me your suggestions
for the filing system it's actually five
suggestions and 23 sub suggestions and
after the briefing oh copy that we got
her posture a little bit increase
criminal activity in the park last night
so we'll be doubling our patrols there
today after the meeting I will be
handing out new
assignments yes
[Music]
killing it Amy I'm Dave but they didn't
sound hopeful well I'm glad you did the
right thing really even though it means
we now have no money for a decent
honeymoon it's hard not to say a really
corny thing right now about how every
day is a honeymoon with you
ah Jake don't freak out there's a really
creepy guy spying on us oh no no no
that's just Phil from nutribboom he'll
be intimidating us from now on there's
an evil Corporation I fail boom boom say
boom boom darling boom boom not a doctor
oh creepy
creepy indeed fun pair of episodes nice
for you know after last week's uh tour
de force it's nice to be back with the
force
what did you think
yeah they are uh the first one was okay
yeah and uh the second one seemed to set
up a plot line that seems like it's
coming in pretty late into the season
sure
but you know it'll be the next three
seasons to come but I do like how it
came back because it he signed that on
the the Halloween Heist episode and
I didn't think anything would ever
become of it so I thought I was just
coming back for a joke I actually like
how it evolved into a big takedown of a
corporation that they now have to embark
on this impossible mission yeah it's an
evil network marketing company yeah
which is great exposing pyramid schemes
Within mlms
um yeah and caption that creepy cold
Vibe I thought was really fun
and but yeah I I honestly what even
happened in the first episode I don't
even remember what happened first
episode was the arsonist with the
crossword puzzle oh yeah those are being
jealous I mean it's clever yeah it's
more clever stuff what was that
um the resolutions were clever what was
the anagram about the movie
oh goodness uh something anus loser
let me pull it up
hahaha yeah I wanted to try and figure
it out I'm sure I'm sure a bunch of
people have already posted the uh just
pull it up on the uh oh yeah you're
right on the screen recording is much
easier yeah you can do it put up you can
do it
there it is right there no keep going
sad anus loser I go in
um let's see lost
is based on a movie and it was a book
I don't remember the clothes yeah
okay classic movie based on a book all
right down
ooh
I wonder if it's real it's got to be
real it no it has to be they they spent
enough time on the other ones
and this is like the exact kind of thing
gone there's no W You Can't Be Gone with
the Wind
uh
um trying to figure it out
Kill a Mockingbird no no no there's way
too much
yeah I'm just sitting here trying to
eliminate all the ideas I would have I
gotta see if
uh
damn I don't want to
I don't want to just type it in I had to
write it down so that way I could mess
with some titles I gotta figure this out
oh
this place
is it real what classic novels have been
made into films
so many okay which letter stands out the
most
I keep coming back to the L for some
reason I feel like L is kind of a
specific I don't know
or the G
could be something good
the word danger be made
ER yes yeah
all right John pull up a wordpad
I'm gonna figure this out
all right
here we go
okay
type it in okay
sad anus
loser I go in okay
now type the word Danger
now remove those letters
and see what we're left with
s anus loss ioi
uh
sorry this is all going to stay in the
video we're gonna figure this out
okay there's got to be a novel a movie
what about something with glass
ah
you can get glass out of this
g l a two s's
what are movies that okay movies that
start with glass or not Glass Onion or
have the word danger that could be based
on a book or a based on books
I have one title that's kind of popping
in my head but I could have sworn
there's a y in the title okay
foreign
copy this
Fairway
can you make that word dangerous
uh yes we have an oau and an S is like
pretty
dangerous
uh is it dangerous liaison yeah holy
is that based on a book I thought
it was dangerously lays on but I was
like is it dangerously liaison
based on his play itself adapted from a
French novel yeah wow good job dude damn
that is it I kept saying in my head I
kept saying dangerously but I was like
yeah why there's good yeah I thought I
was missing letters from an l y so I was
like oh it can't be that sure sure yeah
oh I get it yeah Dangerously
yeah dangerously no and I felt like if
we just
flushed it out to the dangerous weekend
I'll be like well it has to be if it's
that if that's all that's in there okay
wait now let's let's confirm my Google
uh now let's type it in on Google okay
before we celebrate this interview it's
not entirely different Brooklyn nine
nine
answer
okay yeah nice well done yeah yeah we
did it you did it yeah
that was good that was fun that was
thrilling I haven't played a word puzzle
in a game in a while
now I'm just trying to think of what
other possibilities that use all the
letters there are yeah I I don't know if
there could be other choices yeah
anyway
um I mean that we got something out of
that first yeah yeah because what is
what was it that was that in Terry's car
and then the second episode was the
neutral boom and then Amy's Sergeant
Sergeant Hood yeah so yeah definitely
the stronger I think was the Amy episode
Jake being jealous was like mediocre
really funny the jokes are kind of
predictable yeah he's buff he's good
looking yeah yeah he's smart a lot of
that reminded me of a Friends episode uh
there were two jokes in there that were
straight up pulled from friends I don't
remember which jokes they were but I
remember when they said it I was like
the Anna Kournikova joke I was like
that's exactly a joke in friends that
Chandler says and then there was another
joke
that was also a joke Chandler said and
there's a similar episode to friends I
mean it's kind of like a sitcom episode
of just the person's jealous the the
wife hanging out with someone who they
have way more in common with and is
better looking more successful yeah who
plays to their like specifications but
there were like two there's a second
joke that I was like ah straight up from
friends yeah whoever the writer was in
the episode big fan
um
and uh yeah I thought the
the
um
the car thing was whatever I didn't even
see them driving the car left with more
questions I was like who actually
ordered the code they're like they'll
see them Drive in the car yeah let's get
them out in the car but the payoff I
don't know that felt really like it's
weird to say this for a sitcom because
it did feel like a film
but they had the the thing about this I
like the whole thing with the
commissioner yes very that was great
yeah yeah yeah and uh and that was
Alison Tolman I think was the guest
actress who was the you know rival to
whole to I assume we'll see again at
some point
yeah she's a good actress so it's cool
to see her in this kind of comedic
environment and that was a good yeah
like even though a lot of that story
still wasn't like one of my favorite b99
plot lines I thought that was a strong
kind of choice that he made there
like you can kind of see it coming but
it was a nice moment I like that moment
yeah especially to stay true to his
character and especially after Gene has
been hyping him up to to take her down
you know
it was nice like yeah it was like a
pleasant episode it was one of those
ones where I wouldn't be sad you know
binge watching the show to have it on
but it's not one where I'm like yeah
yeah whereas this one at least you know
like the guy who plays uh bill yeah like
he's yeah every time he shows up it's
quite quirky and fun he's a really funny
guy yeah he's a really funny character
um and I love when they choose to take
like a random disparate gag that
probably was never intended for anything
greater and then do that with him like
yeah and that I think is a way of coming
you know it's like sometimes you are
like yeah we need some for these
characters to do and it's very much like
a case of the week but that's a clever
way of of yeah because anyone who
vaguely remembers is going to be like ah
fun you know yeah yeah that was great
um I like the mystery setup it was
getting like kind of spooky yeah totally
and I thought at the end the who's the
guy Jay Jay oh super Shake car when he
when he was uh at the very end I was
like the date like brainwasher no I
thought yeah do something in his
medicine like what's going on in the
show now it felt like they ejected him
with that that stuff that they call like
truth serum is supposed to just make you
kind of you know uh uh malleable and
like open and and sort of loopy yeah
true yeah
I mean yeah and then like it had that
quality words yeah you got you meet the
like over peppy robotic uh rep and then
you have everybody in the like the
awkward interpersonal interactions then
all the stuff with the wife like yeah
like despite the humor it did kind of
start to feel like one of those cult
conspiracy kind of movies in a fun way
um and yeah I don't know yeah this is
like I mean you've seen more of the
insides of network marketing than I have
but it's always a fun kind of I don't
know thing to see different shows take
on it what was the B story uh it was Amy
trying to manage her aiming oh that was
really fun yeah and I wonder if I'm
dealing with a mirror of yourself that's
always a challenge yeah and I I wonder
if we'll ever see any of those other
characters again if we'll see Gary I
hope we see Gary I would like that yeah
I mean seeing her in the sergeant
position and learning to take command I
thought was a great great thanks much
for Amy to like really look at herself
in the mirror because she's she's such a
specific cork kind of a character you
know teacher's pet very much wanting to
be the gold standard at all times and to
be met face to face with that type of
encouraging attitude I thought was
really really funny uh I like I like
that a lot yeah it is easy to get
annoyed with someone who reflects
herself yeah give a taste of your own
medicine yeah that was really fun there
was fun stuff it was overall was fun I
still really love the shirt yeah no it's
always a joy like it's it's been a I
can't think of the last time I would
have seen an episode and been like that
was flat yeah yeah this is some shine
brighter than others but what did you
guys think of these which one did you
like more and what's your favorite
subplot overall leave it in the comments
and before we get out of here let's do a
page
Tyler Hague I want you if I was a cop I
would absolutely want absolutely want
you on my force a part of my precinct
you would be crucial in keeping morale
High you would be crucial in keeping
Spirits calm and you could watch the
entire city like think of what use you
could put your wall of TVs to if you
just had every security camera on all
the streets of Brooklyn Wisconsin Los
Angeles wherever it is you could keep
that watchful eye you could be
everyone's big benevolent brother and uh
yeah I feel like that would just make
everyone's lives a lot nicer people feel
safer and yeah like can you send me a
photo Tyler oh yeah please send a
headshot and a body shot Now's the Time
to audition to that definitely you want
to be a star don't you send in along
with your next pledge this is a few a
few tasteful uh but festive images and
uh you know we'll let you know if you
got what it takes
love you bye see you next time